so yes let's uh let's let's jump to this
first story because i thought it was a
really interesting contrast considering
scott's here and this
is just happening so we have this from
the daily mail nypd commissioner calls
black lives matter protesters spoiled
brats for wasting police resources
after 14 were arrested during last
night's demonstrations over the cop
killing
over the cop killing of a black city
worker in texas commissioner dermot shea
laid into protesters demanding an end to
police brutality and racism
in an interview with ny1 tuesday morning
shea accused them of breaking windows
property damage graffiti
lighting fires and called them spoiled
brats and knuckleheads
knuckleheads that's not particularly
edgy at all but sure
the crazy thing is though i've covered a
lot of protests and riots and stuff and
i shouldn't even say riots in new york
people typically don't go around
starting fires and smashing stuff so
this is like a serious escalation for
new york city
nypd told daily mail 14 were arrested
and 10 summonses issued
new yorkers took to the streets monday
to protest jonathan price's killing
white cop sean david lucas gunned down
price while the black man was trying to
break up a domestic fight at a gas
station in wolf city saturday night
price's death tops off a string of
police killings of black men and women
across america in recent months which
have sparked nationwide protests
i actually take issue with that last
bullet point they got
that it's like uh what does it say um a
string of killings
it's like they're killings all the time
of you know tons of different people
and to insinuate there's like a pattern
or whatever it's kind of you know
whatever
but but you know so there's a couple
things that i wanted to bring up with
this story and we'll just like launch
this into scott who you are and what you
do
the first thing is why is it that a cop
in texas
kills a dude and they go out and protest
the nypd like the nypd have anything to
do with it did smashing that starbucks
window in seattle have anything to do
with it
i kind of feel like they're not really
protesting anything they're just you
know basically yelling rabble rabble
rabble
i don't know if you guys what are your
thoughts as we as we segue now into like
what's going on black lives matter
well violence and hatred don't stop at
borders that's one way to look at it
similar to pollution well i just don't
get why
if black lives matter why don't we see
this kind of
outrage every time every single black
person is killed
why is it only when it's a police
officer or why
is it when it's only uh when the race is
different
of the officer and the victim i mean if
black lives truly matter which they do
but then where is the outrage uh when
illegal immigrants for example kill the
black community we never hear
those stories they never get a protest
they never get a march or demonstration
it's the critical theory power dynamics
it's the the police are the oppressors
in a position of power
and so when you bring up that okay well
what about this guy killing this guy
they're like well that's not authority
even though it kind of still disregards
wealth dynamics and class dynamics
so the real the reality the answer to
question there isn't one
there's no good reason i can't quite
understand it they just don't like cops
i mean they don't they don't say all
oppression
uh all oppressors are bad you know ayobe
they say all cops are bad but
my my question i guess is like what what
what ultimately ultimately do you
accomplish
by screaming in the face of an nypd
officer who has no idea what's going on
in texas
well something happened in texas or
let's be real for a second
i mean why don't these people do
something productive like i believe
about changing a system from the inside
out so if you're fed up with the police
system why don't you become a police
officer
and reform change from within and have
every single one of your black lives
matter people become
police officers or for example in
baltimore why aren't you guys getting
ac conditioner and heater units for
baltimore schools
where the students had to actually leave
school because it was too hot during the
summer when they started why not do
something
productive and you know i'd be so bold
as to say have these people actually
spoken to the black community because i
speak to the black community you know
what they say
they are against defunding the police
because they know that less police
equals more crime so these
people and the leadership roles i don't
think they're actually speaking on
behalf of the black community in general
could you imagine like some black lives
matter dude watching the tv and seeing
the story and then going
ah and fury and then like going outside
and
then like building a house and like you
know putting things together i'm so
angry i'm going to build this house to
help the homeless
it doesn't happen that'd be cool i mean
i know i know i'd be so there
yeah it's like they have all this anger
and they go outside and they just yell
and then everyone runs around smashing
stuff
and doesn't solve any of the problems
and if you try to tell them like hey
let's take that anger and do something
good
they just get angrier like how dare you
i am it's my righteous anger
i love it i i posted something about
some there's this meme on facebook
someone posted and it's like really dumb
they're like if you're anti-antifa that
means you're pro-fascist
oh my gosh and i was like okay so here's
a question like if there's an
islamophobe
who is you know like attacking muslim
people
and i go up to them and like i stop them
from doing it
because i'm anti-islamophobe does that
make me like pro-muslim
and they're like yes and i was like but
i'm not a fan of organized religion in
that capacity so i'm just i'm just
anti-violence
right and they're like well you need to
understand like what you're supporting
when you support fascism
so i asked him straight up if antifa
goes to like a bunch of white antifa go
to a black neighborhood
and start smashing things up and burning
things down does that make them fascists
and they were like it means you don't
understand why they feel that way and
their anger and i'm like oh
now it's justified like so say now now
they're allowed to go and attack
minorities because their their feelings
are hurt
well you know i went to kenosha
wisconsin and i went there
after they burned down several buildings
and i spoke personally to the business
owners
asian business owner hispanic business
owner a black
beauty salon was burned to the ground
you know really how does it help the
black community when you're burning down
a black community center i don't get it
i think they're racists
yeah i mean like we talked about this
last night what prince harry said
you know i can't i can't repeat his
quote
i have to be very careful i say because
it's such an agree like prince harry
said
that he believes the world was created
according to prince harry
by white people and he went on to add
that it was created and this is prince
harry saying this
for white people you see i have to
phrase that so that the context is like
prince harry is the one who said he
believes the world was made for
his race that's racist and so these are
the people who are going around
and that you know i think i'm willing to
bet there's a bunch of people who
they really are white supremacists and
they're given carte blanche because the
media is like so long as they're wearing
hoodies you know they can do whatever
they want
and they do and then afterwards they're
like don't worry we're helping
and then what do you see in these videos
it's locals like there's there's one
video where these two white women are
spray painting and smashing a window and
two black women come up
oh yeah and they're yeah and they're
like get out of here and they're like no
we're helping you
no you aren't get out of my neighborhood
dude i can't imagine
that like what it must be like to live
in this place that's already suffering
and then have these people show up
yelling angry like we're helping
as they like punch you and smash
everything and like flip your car over
and
and then when you beg for help the media
calls you the fascist
yeah or when you clean up a city they
question your motives
that's what i love about what you've
done do you want to explain like what
you've been doing and you know who you
are
sure well my name is scott pressler i
never thought this would be my life i
started off as a dog
walker graduated from george mason with
a 3.63 just fyi is that good but i
oh no it's okay i could have done better
but i couldn't find a job so i walk dogs
because there's no shame in working hard
and a hard day's labor i moved to texas
to help elect governor greg abbott which
is why i'm always wearing texas boots
spent years of my life working to defeat
hillary clinton and now i'm on this
mission to re-elect donald trump
and it was the president when he was
talking about the city of baltimore in
the state
of the city that i decided to tweet on
social media
i'm going to baltimore to go pick up
trash and the tweet went
viral and all these people were wanting
to help and then i was like oh
because i only had six days and we
organized 200 volunteers on a
monday and we picked up 12 tons of trash
in 12
hours in one day in one of the most
dangerous streets west baltimore
in the country and then the baltimore
sun questioned my motives
and said yeah well how dare you how dare
you i have been watching
cnn okay and they've told me that the
people putting the garbage there and
destroying things are the good guys
so clearly that must mean you by
cleaning it up are a bad guy
my logic is is impeccable well or gosh
you know i'm not gonna mention names but
maybe i should just braid my hair and go
around saying how dare you to everyone
yeah that does a lot more than what i've
been doing
yeah ignore the actual polluters why did
they who questioned you
the baltimore sun what was the what were
they saying they were just questioning
why was coming to town if it were
politically motivated
why now um as opposed to hey
how can we help you how can we use our
voice
to amplify and get more volunteers in
our city you know because let's say that
democrats
were organizing a cleanup in fairfax
virginia where i live
i'd say hey you know what good on you
good on you that you're doing something
positive and who knows maybe i'll come
out and join you
and i think we could really make america
a better place if we saw
more cleaning up as opposed to burning
down
stuff that's what they do we actually
have the article check this out this is
uh we assume it was pure motives that
led a trump supporter to launch a
cleanup in cummings district right
from the editorial board how how
ridiculous is this story
the effort was organized by pro-trump
activist scott pressler he claimed the
event was not political
yes he was inspired to come from tweets
from president donald trump describing
the area
represented by u.s rep elijah cummings
as a rodent infested mess
but the visit wasn't about showing
support or animosity for either man he
said
call us skeptical look we appreciate
anyone who's willing to roll up their
sleeves to help baltimore
more than 170 people came from all over
the country and cleaned up nearly 12
tons of trash
according to mr pressler's twitter feed
he doesn't post any photos of the
totality of the trash so let's take his
word for it but if this was all about
americans helping americans why all the
videos of baltimore residents thanking
mr trump
for bringing attention to the issue we
happen to know that not everybody in
west baltimore
feels that way and in the same post as
the videos why the frequent reminders
this is an
uh this is an act this is an act
in act mr cummings district in fact i'm
guessing oh okay
i'm like what is this word happy ending
guys this isn't a year old article come
on fix it
then there's the photo of the washington
post front page from the day barack
obama was first elected
mr pressler tweeted that volunteers
found the strikingly strikingly
unyellowed decade old newspaper among
the trash wow
really it was furry amazing
under trash buried under a pile of trash
i saved it at some point
they had the tweet here this is that's
amazing it's been 11 years
it was sitting there and it's like
preserved that's a mess that's amazing i
thought it was the most
ironic thing that's amazing wow
that's nuts man they say uh uh
uh it's been 11 years mr pressler
tweeted in what reads as a not so subtle
critique of how much good mr obama did
for baltimore
which is none i'd imagine whatever he
says his motives were mr president's
mr pressler's presence in baltimore
reinforces a tired image of our failing
urban cores
that the poor people in this dilapidated
city can take care of their own
neighborhoods
and all the public officials around them
have failed as well the bureaucratic
all talk democrats strike again if a
crowd of volunteers could clean up 12
tons of trash in 12 hours
how incompetent and helpless must
baltimoreans be if they can't manage it
in decades right
okay i'm not going to read the rest of
it but i i i love
how speaking of garbage yeah yeah
absolutely it's not the baltimore sun in
that pile
i love this we all have something to say
about it
go ahead i got to say i i really love
this because
as i've said before if what you were
doing was supposed to be some kind of
manipulation of regular people into
supporting trump
i'm like oh no he's tricked us
rats oh oh i i hope he doesn't do it
again
oh no how many people would support him
clean he's cleaning up garbage why are
you complaining about you'd be like oh
it's really cool that trump supports our
cleaning of garbage let's let's get him
to do it again
and it's like oh scott pressler uh he's
just gonna be nice again yeah
seriously oh we can't have that
apparently not
they were crapping all over you in the
beginning of the article and then they
started crapping all over the residents
of baltimore
so i could think of someone with an
attitude problem seriously
dude i can't believe you found an obama
newspaper
amazing what was it what what what
newspaper was it was it the baltimore
sun
no no the washington post it was the
2008
first election of president obama that
was under so much filth and trash that
it was preserved
and preserved in amber like the bacteria
couldn't
decompose the paper like there was no
water where was the rain
thank you there was so much trash over
it it wasn't getting wet
we in that first cleanup picked up that
12 tons
literally within one block like we we
didn't move
there was so much volume of trash
just piled from head to toe wow
yeah you want to know what i hear when i
listen to this stupid article
i hear a ton of guilt like i
legit think that everything they're
saying about what you believe of them
is them projecting what they're actually
truly about what democrats have done for
baltimore which is nothing i mean it's
just how dare you expose the
shortcomings of our failed politicians
seriously
the shortcomings of comings well and
here's what nobody's talking about too
that a lot of the older residents have
been dying
and the younger people aren't cleaning
it up that's one thing and then also i
met a woman who's
81 years old and she's four foot 10
inches tall i mean the woman is like 100
pounds soaking wet
how is she possibly gonna organize the
cleanup and pick up 12 tons of trash
the fact is it has nothing to do with
them trying to say
it's a tired old stereotype of urban
communities no these people literally
just can't physically do it by
themselves so they need a little bit of
help and that's where we come in what's
wrong with that
you know what's interesting is that one
of the things i see basically you're
saying the young people aren't cleaning
it up i feel like
it's a lack of community that absolutely
results in a lot of this
and so the solution from the left tends
to be give money to the government the
government will clean it up but that
doesn't solve the community problem
it just creates a bureaucratic mess
where you now have administrators who
like
don't really do anything to help they'll
show up they'll clean up
they well actually they're not for
whatever reason
but until you have people who think i'm
going to ask my neighbors
what we can do to make our neighborhood
better you're just going to keep getting
more of this across the country
so i guess my point with this is i think
it's going to start happening everywhere
you look at new york there's no
community there yeah it's kind of an
example of
we're kind of talking about how cities
are starting to fail or at least
starting to rupture and you can see like
people are moving out in the times of
covid it's another example that people
create more trash than they can
necessarily
clean up or or choose to clean up so we
have to have these trash services coming
and if those things can't for whatever
reason get in
or even if they can in this or in this
sense of what baltimore was going
through it seems like
this trash is just going to continue and
maybe it's maybe it's not tenable
how many how many people like how many
of you and everybody listening
have gone to like your neighbor's house
like walked out your door
went to your neighbor and said hey just
want to introduce myself that's not
really happening all that much
these days even if they do because like
where i was living before up in the
philly area
we did go and talk to the neighbors just
like hey what's up here's what you know
we're doing nice to meet you feel free
to ask us for anything and then we never
talk ever again
and then uh this was ten years ago uh
one of our buddies lucrative we are
changed did this video
where he went on the trains in new york
and he
was he was basically saying you have
millions upon millions of people coming
in and off these trains not once they
talk to each other
and so he actually said i'm going to
talk to these people and then he asked a
bunch of like questions about like
government conspiracy it's kind of funny
but uh but it is it is a good point when
when i see that you got the older
generation
they don't have the the wherewithal the
resources the time and energy to
organize cleanups and the younger people
they don't see value in their community
i'm not going to say for everybody
to actually organize this cleanup and
actually do the job
i think what you're doing is extremely
important but how do you inspire them
to to be the next person to come and do
the cleanup or to you to make sure the
garbage doesn't come back you know what
i mean
i just show up i got a buddy justin in
pittsburgh who
after doing a cleanup with him every
single month since we did the cleanup
he's not only been doing his own cleanup
by himself
but also been registering voters so i
created a little mini scot pressler
in pittsburgh oh no no my heart sinks i
love it
that's amazing and so i kind of feel
like i'm a pebble
and i'm just throwing myself in the
water and i'm
hoping that the ripple effect is gonna
you know
happen because i i run a no pressure
campaign you're never
going to inspire somebody to do it by
forcing them to do it and that's what
the democrats don't understand the
difference between republicans and
democrats is republicans want you to
have the freedom to do what you want
democrats want you to
force you to take action and so i
believe that by doing it
positively and with love and just by
doing
something i myself am going to inspire
others to take action
have you heard of the gravel institute i
haven't so there
uh this mike gravel actually i i like
the guy he thinks cool dude and the
people running this
uh i like we talked about them a little
bit because they just launched this like
counter to prageru i just you know my
request is that they tone down the
meanness
of their tweets and stuff like insulting
people because their videos are actually
well made
though i disagree with them i like to
see that the left is putting forward
these arguments
so uh there was a video they put out
today called capitalism versus freedom
and there's a few really interesting
things they say in this
one of which is how is it freedom that
you have to get a job
or starve and i was out my first
reaction was like
i don't understand like if you were in
the middle of the woods and you decided
i'm not gonna do any work you would
starve
what makes them think that they're in a
city that's like special circumstances
that someone else is going to feed you
but they basically make the argument
that because
you have to work you're not free and
because
employers you know set the terms of
employment
you're not actually free therefore i
guess i don't know what their ultimate
argument is about how they
bring about true freedom communism i
guess
so anyway you mentioned the freedom
thing and i was i was lingering on this
greveland student stuff
and so i don't know i'm just thinking
about
who actually wants you to be free
democrats or republicans
and when we were talking we were talking
to uh kim
kimberly klasik she was she was on the
show a few weeks ago
it feels like the one of the reasons
they're probably mad at you
is because for one you're showing people
that
by choice with no expectation of like
money or anything in return you just did
something
yeah and it made everything better and
that's like that's the root
of a job right so you can be like i am
going to build a thing and then you make
it then you go to somebody
i would like to give you this thing in
exchange for i don't know a piece of pie
or something
you don't need to go to a company to
find money but the narrative we get from
any of these leftists is like that's the
only way to do it
therefore we must have communism
otherwise you're not free
then when you show up and you start
making them look bad
it's breaking that stranglehold where
they say basically
if you don't get the solution from us
which they're not really getting in the
first place
then it'll be so much worse when the
reality is they need to actually
like individually i mean everybody not
just baltimore like other places you've
been to
it's got to be community you need people
who live in the area to
to care about the area but i think you
did a cleanup in like los angeles right
i think one of the biggest problems we
have especially with places like los
angeles is that bad
people are in and out like i don't care
i'm not going to stick around this place
is a mess
it's almost like you know when uh
reminds me that uh simpsons joke
where the garbage is piled really really
high and then the rule is whoever knocks
the garbage over has to take it out
so like there's like bart staples a
banana peel to the side of it
they have no interest in in doing better
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you